[Do high fives help sports teams win]
You know, non-human primates
— the closest ones to us — they touch each other all the time
to spread goodwill and to build up
friendships, right
Touch is this very old system by
which we communicate to other people
and we're finding in our lab that, wow, we have this rich vocabulary
of goodwill and, and also we can communicate negative emotions with touch
you know, how do we use that to build up
cooperative communities
so we studied the National Basketball
Association. If you just
look at a basketball court, there's all and this touch going on: High fives, fist bumps,
embraces.
I love how basketball players, like when
they shoot a free throw they have to
now
they all have to like reach for touch two guys,
step back,touch two guys. I mean,
that's incredible, right
and so we took one game of
every team in the NBA at the start of
the year and we coded
allof the touch that happened during
that game. It took us
eight months. Here's what we found, which is that a game is 48 minutes and there's
kind of
summed up about a minute and a half
of touch during that game.
The more that a team touched each other
at the start of the year,
controlling for how much money they're
making, the
expectations that they would do well
during that season, how well they're
doing in that game
that we coded — at the end of the year not
only did they win more games,
but they're really nice basketball
statistics of how
selfless the play is, do they help on
defense, do they set a screen
and the were playing more efficiently
and cooperatively, right, so we think that
touch
is really part have how teams do well.
Should we get a high five for this video?
Let us know by clicking the like button
and if you want to know how power effects the brain, watch this video here